the entire age demographic of those that
are being hospitalized for covet 19 has
changed
and our area hospitals are urging
everybody to get vaccinated to stop the
spread of the disease
dr dominic martinello is the chief
medical officer for
southern hills hospital medical center
right now he's seeing people in their
20s to
50s the vast majority who are
unvaccinated
dealing with the most serious
consequences from the virus so
if you got coveted in the past and
recovered and maybe thought
immunities last 90 to 120 days but all
antibodies are not created equal
and he's urging you to get a vaccine
because he says the second time around
getting cobit is going to be a lot worse
unfortunately it does a tremendous
amount of damage to the lungs up front
so it's a respiratory disease primarily
is what we're seeing so those lungs that
already took a little bit of a hit and
were still healing
now have gotten that second insult it
also generates blood clots which has
been one of the more devastating things
so we are seeing young and otherwise
healthy people with blood clots in the
lungs
blood clots that are causing strokes in
the brain
we've seen a lot of very devastating
issues we've seen myocarditis which is
inflammation of the heart muscle
so he says these individuals are dealing
with complications that last six maybe
nine months even a year after they get
infected or re-infected
so he's urging everyone get vaccinated
and maintain
social distancing